almost two full years ago we made a
video discussing how intel lost the cpu
race
as well as how they'll eventually lose
apple's business
when apple transitions to arm which
would then be followed by
other companies switching to arm as well
and since that video was published apple
has already transitioned to apple
silicon
with their m1 chip and intel has already
begun to lose
apple's business so a few months ago we
made an updated video discussing how
apple's m1 max
put the last nail in intel's coffin and
then two months ago we made another
video discussing how intel
is already beginning to lose the
business of other companies
with nvidia and amd switching to arm
chips
and today this video will prove that x86
is dying sooner than you think and you
won't believe
who is holding the weapon this time to
begin this story we've gotta go way back
to an old ars technical article
from way back in 2011 discussing the
fate of x86
according to john stokes it wouldn't
take much
for arm to take out x86 he claimed that
if it turns out that the arm ecosystem
can get within a factor of 2
of x86 in terms of performance and
performance per watt
and if that ecosystem can keep the cost
of arm chips
lower than that of x86 then arm would
essentially do to x86
what x86 did to all of the long
forgotten architectures
from back in the day apparently intel's
x86 was able to take over
by making products that were
dramatically cheaper and
almost as good and that was enough to
make x86 the most popular architecture
for many years until today as you all
know
apple's new m1 chip which is the very
first
apple silicon mac chip is beating every
other
intel x86 chip in terms of single core
performance
and not only that but the m1's
performance per watt is absolutely
mind-blowing
when you compare it to what intel has to
offer in both the consumer
and workstation markets now going back
to the article
he said that it's possible that
competition in the arm ecosystem
could get performance up to intel's
territory without
ever beating it while being much cheaper
due to massively higher product volumes
well guess what the m1 chip in apple's
low end macbooks is already
outperforming
the x86 intel chips from even the
highest end notebooks
like the 16 inch macbook pro and on top
of that
it's also much cheaper for apple to
manufacture as well
since they're pushing mass production of
the m1 chip to the max
with the same exact chip going into five
of their products
and according to analysts this switch
alone will save apple around 40 to 60
percent on cpu component costs which is
absolutely insane but the mind-blowing
thing is that the m1 chip is also
offering much better battery life like
in one of our comparisons
where our 16-inch macbook pro was just
about
dead while the m1 was still at around 67
battery life after three and a half
hours of performance testing and on top
of that
we've recently been seeing many
consumers including windows pc
fans migrating over to the mac just
because of how good the new
m1 macbook air and other m1 max are and
the crazy thing is that apple is just
getting started
because their m1x macbook pros are going
to be launching within the next couple
of months
and i personally believe that those
macbooks
will revolutionize the entire industry
so in reality
that article scenario for the death of
x86
has already been reached today and
according to ars technica
the x86 pc will become a boutique
high performance niche machine and that
basically means
its curtains closed for intel unless of
course
they jump back on the arm bandwagon and
at that point
if our vendors catch up which apple
obviously already has
intel would be left with two options the
first
option would be to make its own mobiles
desktops tvs and
other devices which they obviously
haven't started doing
so that leaves them with the second
option go back
into the arm business potentially even
opening up their chip
fabrications to produce arm-based socs
from other companies and based on what's
been happening over the past couple of
months
that's obviously where intel is headed
so let me explain
a couple of months back intel started an
obviously desperate ad campaign
going against apple and their new m1 max
and shortly after that
intel ceo pat gelsinger revealed plans
for their new intel foundry services
business
where they would manufacture apples and
other companies arm-based chips for
them which is exactly what rs technica
predicted
way back in 2011. this action by intel
speaks
louder than words because if their x86
chips were the future
they would have made plans to use those
two brand new foundries
to build their own x86 chips and make
much more profit
but no they're gonna build the very
arm-based chips
that led to the demise of x86 now if you
want more evidence of
intel eventually ditching x86 here you
go
earlier this month it was rumored that
intel made a 2.1 billion dollar offer
to buy out sci-5 and if you don't know
who or what that
is you're about to have your mind blown
sci-fi
is a company established by researchers
who invented
the risk 5 instruction set architecture
and they are the world's first developer
of commercial risk 5 chips
risk 5 is basically the open source
version of
arm so companies can make risk 5 chip
designs
without having to pay a licensing fee
like
apple for example who bought a generic
arm license
many years ago in order to make their
own apple silicon chip designs
and going back to sci-5 around six years
ago
they unveiled their new business model
which is to basically design
risk 5 based chips for other companies
like
intel so you might be asking why would
intel go and spend
so much cash to buy this company if they
can just design
their own risk 5 chips without paying a
licensing fee
well it turns out that sci-5 has already
been making their own high-performance
chip designs
for many years like the u8 series chip
to sell to other companies who want to
use it so if intel buys outside 5
they'll basically be able to take
whatever sci-5 has made
and rebranded as a brand new intel risk
5 based chip
to compete against apple's m1 and future
apple silicon mac chips
and guess what just happened a couple of
weeks ago sci-5
had a massive press release where they
revealed intel's
true plans apparently intel's new
foundry services business
including intel's two brand new
foundries in arizona
will be used to manufacture sci-fi's ip
on top of that intel is creating their
own risc-5 development platform
using its 7 nanometer process technology
called horse creek which will combine
several of
brand new performance p550 cores
and intel's own ddr and pcie
ip technology so yeah intel
literally just entered the chat to
battle apple's m1 ship
and to be completely honest it's the
best move that they could have ever made
but check out this next part because
it's by far the most
telling detail back in march intel
announced their next generation
7 nanometer chiplets for their meteor
lake chips
which are going to be their very first
seven nanometer x86 based chips
that will reach volume production in
2023
however intel actually lied because
their true plans were revealed
in the sci-fi press release apparently
the brand new
horse creek risk 5 based silicon will be
ready in 2022
which actually makes horse creek intel's
very
first seven nanometer product and it's
not going to be x86 based
this basically shows that intel is doing
everything they possibly can
to rush out a risk five based chip as
fast as possible
even putting it ahead of their own x86
chip designs
and if you're wondering why you probably
haven't seen our reviews of the m1
macbook air
or perhaps dave 2d's review where he
basically recommended the m1 air
over any other windows laptop in its
price range
so because of that intel absolutely
needs to act fast
and get a competing chip onto the market
asap
or else they're gonna lose too much
market share to apple's m1
and m1x max but wait it's not just
apple because nvidia's already announced
that they're working with mediatek
to produce an arm-based gaming laptop
with
rtx graphics to compete with intel-based
laptops
not only that but microsoft has already
announced that they're designing their
own
arm-based chips for servers and surface
pcs
including laptops to compete with intel
and
apple and going even further samsung has
already announced
their new arm-based galaxy book go
laptop
for only 349 which uses qualcomm's
snapdragon
7c gen2 chip but wait it gets even worse
for intel
because just a couple of days ago
qualcomm announced plans to compete with
intel and apple silicon chips
by creating a brand new chip that's
apparently supposed to be faster
than apple's m1 chip and that's all
because earlier this year
qualcomm bought out nuvia which was
founded by three
former apple chip designers to basically
create
custom cpu core designs like apple is
currently doing
and the reason qualcomm bought them out
was to reduce the reliance on arm
which is being purchased by nvidia and
apparently qualcomm will already begin
selling custom silicon new via base
laptop ships
in 2022. so what we're seeing here from
all of these massive companies
is a very direct and obvious reaction to
apple's m1 max
with all of them desperately ditching
x86 laptop chips
as fast as they possibly can in an
effort to compete with apple silicon
as soon as next year so based on all of
that
it's now completely obvious why intel
themselves
are ditching their very own x86 laptop
chips
and replacing them with sci-fi's risk 5
based laptop chips that will be
launching in
2022 and now the only piece of the
puzzle left unanswered is the fact that
the armed version of windows
currently sucks but guess what microsoft
just announced last week windows 11 on
arm will now support arm 64 ec
which is basically a new abi that runs
with native speed
and is interoperable and to put it more
simply
they're making it easier for developers
to port their apps over to windows
11 on arm without having to recompile
the entire app
so microsoft is essentially creating a
version
of apple's rosetta 2 but for windows 11.
and on top of that microsoft has
announced 64-bit versions of office
for windows 11 on arm including all of
their popular apps
like word and excel so if you thought
that windows 11 was disappointing
like how they kept the same old and
clunky code base
that's because microsoft's efforts were
focused on
arm and seeing as microsoft themselves
are planning to make their own
arm-based chips it basically shows that
they're also planning to ditch
x86 in the future so with all of that
said
it's pretty obvious why all of these
companies are racing
to ditch x86 in order to compete with
apple's m1 max
and the final nail in the coffin is the
fact that
intel the creators of x86 are ditching
their own chips and using sci-fi's wrist
5 base designs
to compete with apple and everybody else
next year
so yeah like the title of this video
says
x86 will die sooner than you think
now if you completely disagree with my
thoughts on this topic
go ahead and leave your comments down
below but if you enjoyed this video
definitely click the circle about to
subscribe
watch one of those two videos right
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video